bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant un débat sur le climat
et l'énergie en Europe un débat demandé
ici au Sénat par le groupe écologiste
alors vous le savez la France accueera
la conférence climat en 2015 objectif la
négociation d'un nouvel accord universel
sur le d'ici la fin de l'année selon
Laurent Fabius le ministre des Affaires
étrangères il est essentiel que cet
accord comporte des engagements de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre alors par ce débat que vous
allez donc pouvoir suivre le Sénat veut
faire valoir ses arguments sur la
transition énergétique comment favoriser
la transition vers les énergies
renouvelables c'est la question que vont
tenter de se poser les
sénateurs l'ordre du jour jour appelle
le débat sur le climat et l'énergie en
Europe à la demande du groupe écologique
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce dépat à
savoir Monsieur Renand Dantec pour le
groupe écologiste pour une durée de 20
minutes vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue
nous
irons monsieur le Président Madame
madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je l'ai noté le débat que nous
engageons cet après-midi est je pense
que nous en sommes tous convaincus d'une
importance essentielle les réponses que
nous apporterons sur les problématiques
énergétiques sont au cœur de l'avenir du
projet européen et plus largement encore
dirons notre ambition notre stratégie et
notre capacité collective à participer à
une véritable régulation mondiale sur le
développement économique et le
changement climatique
autrement dit sur la paix mondiale pour
l'Europe les enjeux sont parfaitement
connus tout d'abord il s'agit d'assumer
d'assurer l'autonomie énergétique du
continent toujours très dépendant des
importations d'énergie fossile l'Union
européenne importe 40 % de son charbon
60 % de son gaz et 80 % de son pétrole
en 2012 la facture énergétique de
l'Union européenne était de 428
milliards en France la même année le
déficit de la balance énergétique s'é
bliss ainsi à plus de 68 milliards
d'euros tandis que le déficit de la
balance commerciale globale s'élev elle
à 67 milliards d'euros on voit avec ces
chiffres que notre déficit de balance
commerciale globale est du même ordre de
grandeur que le déficit de la balance
énergétique autrement dit si nous étions
autonomes en énergie notre balance
commerciale serait à
l'équilibre l'économie européenne
souffre de cette dépendance énergétique
qui a renforcé ce n'est peut-être pas
assez dit l'évolution d'un capitalisme
industriel vers un capitalisme financier
dont nous subissons chaque jour le
cinisme il faut en effet souligner
qu'une part très importante des
ressources des grands fonds souverains
et spéculatifs sont alimentés en plus de
l'épin des fonds de pension américains
par ces immenses masse financière généré
par l'achat par les pays développés des
matières premières énergétiques dont
elles ont besoin cette dépendance aux
énergie fossiles n'est évidemment pas
non plus sans conséquence sur nos
stratégies géopolitiques tant nous
devons ménager les pays exportateurs
avec qui plus est des différences
notables de fournisseurs et donc des
intérêts différents entre les pays
européens la crise ukrainienne est là
aujourd'hui pour souligner cette
dépendance et cette difficulté de
stratégie commune mais je crois
néanmoins qu'un consensus existe
aujourd'hui en Europe pour considérer
que l'avenir économique du continent
passe par la réduction de sa dépendance
aux importations d'énergie fossile et
qu'il s'agit d'une priorité en terme
d'emploi il s'agit donc maintenant de
traduire cette objectif en une politique
européenne de l'énergie cohérente et
volontariste et aux conséquences
bénéfique bien au-delà du champ de
l'énergie le deuxième enjeu est
évidemment la réponse à la crise
climatique dont l'extrême gravité est
plus visible chaque jour le dernier
rapport du GC a insisté sur le fait que
nous allions vers des événements
climatiques extrêmes de plus en plus
graves chaque semaine l'actualité nous
en donne des exemples et j'ai une pensée
avec vous aujourd'hui pour ceux qui sont
touchés par les inondations en Bosnie le
dernier rapport du GC précise
particulièrement les graves conséquences
du changement climatique sur la sécurité
alimentaire dans les pays du Sud je le
cite tous les aspects de la sécurité
alimentaire sont potentiellement
affectés par le changement climatique la
production de blé de maïs et de riz
devrait être affecté d'ici à la fin du
siècle quel que soit le niveau de
réchauffement soyons clair à ce niveau
et avec cette rapidité le changement
climatique déstabilise profondément bien
des pays et pas seulement les plus
pauvre il réduira tous les efforts de
développement aggravera tension guerre
civile et terrorisme et ce n'est pas
pour rien si ce sont les agences de
sécurité et l'armée qui aux États-Unis
sont les principaux défenseurs d'un
accord climatique ambitieux 3ème enjeu
la précarité énergétique qui s'aggrave à
mesure que le coût de l'énergie augmente
3,8 millions de ménag de France
métropolitaine ont aujourd'hui un taux
d'effort énergétique supérieur à 10 % de
leur revenus tandis que 3,5 millions
déclarent souffrir du froid dans leur
logement selon le Comité économique et
social européen la pauvreté énergétique
toucherait aujourd'hui 50 millions
d'Européens les conséquences sont
multiples le frein à la mobilité impacte
l'emploi le manque de chauffage affecte
l'hygiène la santé c'est une cause
importante de sur endettement les
personnes concernées étant condamné à
des arbitrages indigne d'une société
développée entre manger ou se chauffer
se chauffer ou s'endetter cette urgence
doit être en tête de nos priorités
politiques la réponse à ces différents
enjeux ne peut pas être que nationale
nous nous félicitons donc du discours
tenu par François Hollande sur la
nécessité d'une approche européenne de
ces questions par exemple dans sa
tribune publiée dans Le Monde du 6 mai
où il déclarait la crise ukrainienne
doit encore accélérer l'Europe de
l'énergie pour sécuriser nos
approvisionnements maintenir des prix
compétitifs et lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique nous devons
saluer une approche qui amorce une
évolution par rapport à cette fameuse
tradition française une tradition fondée
depuis les années 60 sur un choix unique
au monde et qui est sans nul doute aussi
aujourd'hui une des grandes fragilités
économiques de la France le choix vous
l'aviez reconnu du tout nucléaire à
l'heure où la quasi-totalité des États
qui nous entourent ferment leur centrale
nucléaire réinscrire la France dans
l'Europe de l'énergie n'est donc pas si
simple il fallait se dégager d'une
mentalité de village gaulois assiégé
craignant de voir déferler sur lui les
légions des grandes multinationales
européennes de l'électricité voulant en
finir avec notre Obélix national certes
tomberé dans le chaudron d'une potion
magique à l'uranium enrichi mais quand
même bien trop isolé pour lutter contre
une telle coalition depuis l'élection de
François Hollande cette inscription de
la France dans une stratégie énergétique
européenne est donc devenue une
constante du discours présidentiel il
faut le souligner il faut le soutenir
ainsi dans le cadre du débat national
sur la transition énergétique Delphine
bateau avait tenu aussi à inviter le
ministre allement de l'énergie de
l'époque Peter almerayer qui était venu
dire à Paris le destin lié des modèles
énergétiques et électriques des deux
pays et rappeler que c'est sur l'énergie
et la c que c'était construit l'Europe
le le président de la République a
depuis parlé d'un projet d'erbus de
l'énergie ce projet ne s'est pas
vraiment précisé depuis mais on voit
bien qu'une volonté existe et qu'il faut
donc la transformer en acte concret
aujourd'hui il faut donc passer des
déclarations aux décisions et pour cela
il nous faut donc une stratégie
européenne forte nous sommes dans un
moment clé de définition de cette
stratégie puisque l'Union européenne
discute actuellement de ces objectifs
énergieclimat pour 2030 qui prendront la
relève du paquet énergie climat de 2008
et du fameux 3 x 20 du paquet 2020 - 20
% de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre amélioration de 20 %
d'eff efficacité énergétique et 20 %
d'énergie renouvelable la Commission
européenne a présenté en janvier sa
première copie qui devait être adopté au
Conseil européen de mars dernier mais
l'actualité ukrainienne et bien d'autres
considérations liées au calendrier
politique européen ont quelque peu
bouleversé l'ordre du jour et les chefs
d'État ont reporté les discussions au
Conseil européen d'octobre prochain ce
sera madame la ministre un rendez-vous
particulièrement important les
propositions qui sont aujourd'hui sur la
table ne brillent mal heureusement pas
par leur ambition - 40 % de réduction de
gaz à effet de serre par rapport à 1990
soit un niveau insuffisant pour
s'inscrire sur la trajectoire d'une
réduction de 80 à 95 % en 2050 et un
objectif qui finalement ne nécessite
guerre d'augmenter l'effort tant c'est
aujourd'hui à peu de chose près la pente
européenne naturelle de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de ser - 27 %
d'énergie renouvelable dans la
consommation finale mais objectif non
décliné en objectifs nationaux et qui
sont très en dessous du potentiel nous
ne nous expliquons pas Madame la
Ministre cette absence de volontarisme
des négociateurs français sur ce point
sachant que sans des objectifs nationaux
précis les efforts risquent d'être
faibles et disparate enfin 3oème point
aucun objectif sur la réduction de la
consommation d'énergie et ce dans
l'attente de la révision par la
Commission européenne de la directive
sur l'efficacité énergétique de 2012
après la compilation don donc des plans
nationaux qui lui sont actuellement
envoyés sur cet objectif 2030 les
discussions portent aujourd'hui sur des
scénarios allant de 25 à 40 % de
réduction de la consommation mais même
dans le cas où un objectif de 40 %
serait retenu c'est très en de ça du
potentiel et j'espère donc madame la
ministre que vous nous rassurerez sur la
volonté de la France de soutenir des
objectifs particulièrement ambitieux les
eurodéputés écologistes regrettent
aujourd'hui ce manque d'ambition et ont
porté une toute autre visision lors des
discussions sur la résolution du
Parlement européen en février nous
proposons notamment d'inverser la
logique en considérant donc d'abord
l'objectif de réduction de la
consommation d'énergie qui doit être un
point de départ à la stratégie sur la
part des HR puisque évidemment si la
consommation finale est réduite la part
des ENR augmente mathématiquement et
enfin en 3oème temps aller sur la
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de ser qui se trouvent eux aussi
renforcés par les deux premiers
objectifs s'ils sont ambitieux nous
proposons donc - 40 % de réduction de la
consommation d'énergie primaire par
rapport à 2010 ce qui équivaudrait à 47
% par rapport aux projections 2030
utilisé par la Commission européenne et
par ricocher au moins 45 % d'énergie
renouvelable dans la consommation finale
et cela entraîne mathématiquement vous
avez eu le temps de faire le calcul une
réduction de 60 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre par rapport à
1990 on comprend bien que sans ces trois
objectifs contraignants et décliné à
l'échelle nationale nous ne pourrons pas
répondre au défis climatiques s'il ne
vous est peut-être pas possible madame
la ministre de nous livrer dès
aujourd'hui la position de la France
dans le cadre des négociations
européennes de l'automne nous voudrions
quand même être un peu rassuré car c'est
vrai que jusqu'à présent la France ne
s'est guerre différencié des
propositions de la Commission européenne
pourtant notoirement insuffisante
j'aimerais m'arrêter maintenant un
moment sur la question plus précise de
la directive sur l'efficacité
énergétique l'un des trois piliers du 3
x 200 cette directive a été adoptée en
2012 après l'excellent travail réalisé
par son rapporteur notre collègue
écologiste luxembourgeois Claude Turmes
et j'en euh j'en profite pour signaler
que nous avons aujourd'hui une nouvelle
ministre écologiste de l'environnement
au Luxembourg Carole dbourg ça n'est pas
tout à fait rien puisque c'est le
Luxembourg qui présidera l'Union
européenne pendant les négociations
climatiques elle sera un soutien pour un
accord ambitieux à Paris conformément à
ce qui a été prévu la France a remis fin
avril à la Commission européenne son
plan national d'action pour l'efficacité
énergétique pour exposer donc la
déclinaison nationale de la directive si
on peut suer la France par le fait
qu'elle ait remise ce document dans les
temps ça pas toujours été le cas surtout
euh au niveau européen pour la France et
plusieurs éléments malgré tout suscitent
des interrogations d'abord la France se
fixe un double objectif conformément à
l'article 3 de la directive de réduire
sa consommation énergétique à 131
mégatep d'énergie final et 236 d'énergie
primaire en 2020 l'article 2 de la
directive précise que consommation
d'énergie primaire s'entend comme la
consommation intérieure brute à
l'exclusion des utilisations non
énergétiques or dans le tableau de
ventilation sectorielle des
consommations d'énergie en 2020 on
constate que cette valeur de 230 236
inclut la consommation finale non
énergétique qui s'élève à 16 millions t
vous me suivez toujours au sens de la
directive l'objectif de la France en
consomm tion d'énergie primaire devrait
donc être plutôt aux alentour de 220
pourriez-vous madame la ministre nous
éclairer sur la façon dont a été réalisé
ce calcul sans rentrer trop dans les
détails techniques et pourquoi il semble
donc toujours contredire les règles
fixées par la directive elle-même ce qui
de fait le diable est toujours dans les
détails réduit notre effort de
consommation de réduction de la
consommation d'énergie par ailleurs ce
plan mise particulièrement sur
l'efficacité énergétique des bâtiments
en lien avec des objectifs très
ambitieux annoncé par le gouvernement
français rénovation thermique de 500000
logements d'ici 2017 dans 380000
rénovations par an dans l'habitat privé
et 120000 dans le logement social il
nous semble pourtant que sur niveau
d'ambition de ces objectifs est louable
les moyens nécessaires normatifs et
financiers ne sont pas mis à disposition
pour les atteintes mais nous allons
avoir donc maintenant rapidement des
indications sur ce point avec la
publication dans les prochains jours du
projet de loi sur la transition
énergétique je reste comme toujours
optimiste sur l'ambition de la loi mais
c'était l'occasion de rappeler ici que
sans ces mesures financières et
réglementairire la France n'atteindra
pas ses objectifs européens en terme
d'efficacité
énergétique justement avec les
informations déjà reçues la Commission
estime que la réduction de la
consommation d'énergie finale dans
l'union sera de 17 % donc moins que les
20 % normalement fixés on voit bien donc
qu'il faut pousser à la fois des
objectifs très ambitieux pour 2030 mais
qu'il ne faut pas non plus baisser la
garde sur les objectifs pour 2020 y
compris dans le débat climatique ce que
nous ferons entre 2015 et 2020 date du
d'application du nouvel accord sera tout
à fait essentiel je voulais donc madame
la ministre vous sensibiliser sur ce
point et si c'est à l'automne que se
décidera en partie lors de la
négociation européenne les objectifs
pour l'Europe c'est là aussi à l'automne
que se jouera la crédibilité de l'Europe
dans la négociation sur le climat à ce
propos et ce sera une des questions de
la conférence climat à Paris il est plus
que temps d'engager une véritable
réforme du système européen d'échange de
quôtas d'émission pour faire remonter le
prix de la tonne carbone les écologistes
avaient approuvé le l'adoption en 2013
du report de la mise aux enchères ou
backloading de 900 millions de quotas
jusqu'en
2019-220 mesure d'urgence nécessaire
mais qui n'est pas à la hauteur puisque
le prix de la tonne est toujours à 5 €
de laave même de la Commission
européenne il y a un excédent de plus de
2 milliards de quotas sur le marché du
carbone européen et sa proposition de
régler une partie du problème par la
mise en place d'une réserve de stabilité
du marché en début de prochaine période
ne résoudra probablement rien c'est une
réforme structurelle du marché dont nous
avons besoin l'Allemagne plaide
d'ailleurs pour aller plus loin et plus
vite pour réguler le marché et faire
remonter le prix de la tonne carbone
consciente qu'avec un prix du carbone si
faible le charbon restera l'énergie la
plus compétitive et qu'il sera donc
extrêmement difficile d'atteindre les
objectifs climatiques la position de nos
voisins allemands et donc qu'on ne peut
pas attendre 2020 pour agir cette
urgence de la remontée du prix de la
tonne carbone est aussi réclamée par les
grands énergéticiens européens dont les
grands énergéticiens français qui se
lamentent des atermoiements européens
sur ce point notamment dû au blocage des
groupes libéraux et conservateurs au
Parlement européen dont les leaders ne
sont pas les dernier a déclaré la main
sur le cœur l'urgence de l'action
climatique mais ne perd pas une occasion
pour torpiller dans les couloirs et les
hémicycles toute ambition européenne en
la matière pourtant sauver le marché du
carbone européen c'est aussi renforcer
la compétitivité de nos grands groupes
déjà résolument impliqués dans la
transition énergétique tout en
renforçant donc nos chances d'atteindre
les objectifs climatiques en rendant
charbon et encore plus gaz de schiste
trop cher nous devrions chercher ici des
consensus y compris y compris en aidant
les Polonais à se dégager du charbon
c'est par le renforcement de la
solidarité européenne que nous
avanceront non par la stigmatisation ce
qui impliquerait aussi un véritable
budget européen vous le voyez tout est
lié je le soulligne enfin le marché
carbone est une opportunité de dégager
des financements plus importants pour
les États-membres la recette ets tombant
directement dans la caisse des états
ceci pourrait donc avoir cette recette
pour financer la transition énergétique
et peut-être aussi pour abonder ce
fameux fond vert ces 100 milliards de
dollars pour le sud promis sur un coin
de table lors d'une négociation nocturne
une nuit de 2009 à Copenhague la
solidarité avec les pays en
développement en leur donnant des moyens
à la hauteur des enjeux d'atténuation et
d'adaptation auxquels ils font face sera
un élément central du futur accord de
Paris en 2015 nous ne devons jamais le
perdre de vue autre piste de financement
dans un contexte de dépenses publiques
extrêmement contraintte les taxations
des transactions financières sur lequel
vous le savez les écologistes ont
toujours été très mobilisés nous avions
quelques espoirs 11 États membres de
l'Union viennent de s'engager à lancer
une taxe sur les transactions
financières européennes mais après avoir
été motrice sur ce point la France
semble aujourd'hui plus mesurée
pouvez-vous madame la ministre nous
rassurer au moins nous éclairer sur
cette question cette approche européenne
des enjeux énergétiques nécessite enfin
une logique de planification moins
autocentré moins franco-française il
faut par exemple renforcer les
interconnexions des réseaux électriques
aux frontières et mettre en place à
l'échelle de l'Europe des mécanismes de
capacité visant à assurer le maintien
d'une capacité de production électrique
suffisante pour faire face au points de
consommation on estime qu'une approche
européenne du mécanisme de capacité
diviserait les coûts par deux cette
logique d'intégration est connue
interconnexion et marché de capacité
commun vont réduire les besoins
d'installation en puissance
supplémentaire c'est l'intérêt général
mais ils vont aussi mettre en évidence
plus rapidement les surcapacités
électriques européennes et plus
précisément dans un contexte européen et
maintenant français de monter en
puissance rapide des énergies
renouvelables ils vont accélérer la
fermeture inéluctable de centrale
nucléaires sans déboucher pour leur
production l'hypothèse de la fermeture
de 20 tranches nucléaires à fermé en
France à horizon 2025 et aujourd'hui
assumé par votre ministère et je me
réjouis que vous ayez encore hier
confirmé les grand objectifs français du
président de la République mais le
diable est parfois dans les détails dans
des décisions prises dans un temps et
des périmètres différents j'attire
notamment votre attention madame la
ministre sur le fait que les décrets
actuellement en discussion en France sur
le futur mécanisme de capacités devront
être compatibles avec cette volonté
d'intégration européenne et non
continuer de participer d'une ligne
maginau de la politique électrique
française dont on connaît les
conséquences à terme sur la
fragilisation de l'économie française je
vous ne demande évidemment pas cet
après-midi madame la ministre de réponse
technique précise sur ces points mais
juste rappeler à quel point dans ce
débat il faut toujours de la cohérence
entre grands objectifs et et décisions
techniques précises de même mais je n'ai
pas le temps d'y revenir il nous
faudrait analyser les conséquences
précises des dernières directives sur le
soutien financier aux énergies
renouvelables voir revenir sur la
question des concession hydraulique
c'est un dossier que vous suivez
particulièrement dans le moment dans le
cadre des réglementations européennes
tout cela pour souign à quel point que
quand on tire le fil le fil électrique
de l'ensemble des enjeux liés à
l'énergie on est dans un débat d'une
grande complexité où chaque décision
même minime doit être vu à l'ône de la
vision d'ensemble de nos priorités
principales ce sera aussi l'enjeu de la
future loi sur la transition énergétique
dernier point en conclusion je sais que
vous êtes madame la ministre très engagé
sur cette approche positive de la
transition écologique et énergétique
c'est la question de l'emploi et des
opportunités de développement de
filières économiques dans le domaine de
de la recherche sur l'énergie solaire
sur le stockage d'électricité sur
l'éolien offshore la France est forte
surtout et on pourrait même dire enfin
que nous voyons nos grands leaders
industriels du secteur énergétique
s'investir sur ces domaines d'avenir
défendre par exemple un objectif
européen de 30 % d'énergie renouvelable
en 2030 c'est la quasi garantie de
création d'un million d'emplois en
Europe à l'échelle mondiale un accord
sur le climat c'est une dynamique forte
y compris pour l'accès à l'énergie
propre et renouvelable dans les pays du
Sud ce sont des marchés considérable sur
lesquels nous devons être présents c'est
donc la nécessité de construire un
leader européen du photovoltaïque adossé
à une recherche où la France est en ple
position c'est également la
restructuration des filières éoliennes
terrestres et offshore qui sont
aujourd'hui la réponse énergétique clé
en Europe avec un mégawur éolien
terrestre nettement moins cher que le
nucléaire c'est donc une véritable
stratégie industrielle coordonnée au
niveau européen qu'il faut construire
dans un délit court nous avons perdu
trop de temps à nier en restant bloqué
dans la bulle du tout nucléaire la force
de cette mutation mon mondial du
paradigme énergétique le cas d'strum et
j'en finirai là en est l'illustration je
suis aujourd'hui très inquiet madame la
ministre pour l'avenir de la filière
éolienne d'stom en bassloire
illustration de nos faiblesses et de nos
retards je ne vous demanderai évidemment
pas quel choix le gouvernement a retenu
entre Siemens et Géral électrique mais
notons néanmoins que dans ce cas la
modeste filière de fabrication en
basselire sur une technologie spécifique
n'aura guerre de poids face aux très
grandes usines du nord de l'Europe dans
un cas mais aussi dans le are cas dans
le cas d'un rapprochement prévisible
avec Areva qui a développé au Havre une
autre unité de fabrication et une autre
technologie cette question de l'emploi
en basselire sur l'éolien offshore et
aujourd'hui posé ce ce point montre
juste à quel point nous avons pris du
retard ce retard ne se rattrapera pas
mais nous ne devons plus nous laisser
distancer avec des entreprises trop
petites et souvent en concurrence les
unes avec les autres je compte donc
madame la ministre sur votre engagement
résolu sur ces questions c'est l'avenir
de la France et de l'Europe qui se joue
ici merci mon cher
collègue dans la suite du débat la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Claude Lenoir
pour 17
minutes bien monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre mes chers collègues
et je remercie mes collègues écologistes
qui ont manifesté beaucoup
d'enthousiasme au moment où je suis
monté à cette tribune peut-être était
simplement les relents de l'enthousiasme
qui avait accompagné la prise de parole
de leur
intervenant en prenant connaissance du
sujet qui nous réunit aujourd'hui qui a
été fixé à l'ordre du jour je n'ai pas
manqué de de sourire car les écologistes
nous invitent un débat sur le climat et
l'énergie en Europe vous nous offrez mes
chers collègues une magnifique occasion
de souligner les acquiss les avantages
les atouts de la France éventuellement
aussi de dénoncer un certain nombre d'
d'erments qui sont malheureusement le
fruit de choix qui ont été fait par
d'autres pays que le
nôtre climat et énergie en Europe je me
permettrai madame la ministre formuler
un certain nombre d'observations que
certains pourront interpréter comme des
recommandations par rapport à ce qui
pourrait être la position de la France
dans le débat européen sur ces
questions première chose il faut
souligner l'avance incontestable que la
France a pu acquérir dans la lutte
contre les gaz à effet de serre et les
émissions de CO2 nous disposons d'une
avance qui se traduit par un
chiffre comparons la France et
l'Allemagne
la France si vous
ramenez le CO2 par unité alors
comptabilisé qui prend en compte le fait
que il n'y a pas que le CO2 mais
également les gaz à effet de
serre vous avez une émission par
habitant qui est de à peu près 7000
tonnes en France quand il est de 12000
tonnes en
Allemagne cela est dû bien sûr à un
certain nombre de choix qui ont été
faits mais lorsque vous dénoncez les gaz
à effet de serre et les émissions de CO2
mes chers collègues interrogez-vous pour
savoir si l'Allemagne a fait les bons
choix or cette avance nous est utile
pour nous
permettre et bien de disposer d'un temps
qui est nécessaire dans le cadre de la
transition énergétique pour aborder
cette question avec sérénité et avec la
recherche d'une meilleure
efficacité seconde observation
contrairement à à ce qui était dit par
celui qui m'a précédé à cette tribune la
consommation d'électricité va augmenter
alors j'ai noté effectivement mon cher
collègue que toute votre démonstration
consistait à calquer la politique que
vous préconisez sur celle de l'Allemagne
quand vous dites - 40 % de consommation
d'énergie primaire c'est la politique de
l'Allemagne mais regardons la France
nous avons pu estimer que d'ici à 2050
la consommation d'électricité allait
augmenter de 20 % à raison de 05 % par
an pour des raisons évidentes qui sont
d'abord démographiques par rapport à
l'Allemagne qui tiennent compte
également des évolutions technologiques
du recours à un certain nombre de
technologies qui consomment beaucoup
d'électricité je pense notamment à tout
ce qui concerne le numérique et
l'informatique et puis troisièmement il
y a aussi les transferts les transferts
fa constater du foule et et du pétrole
vers d'autres usages notamment je pense
à l'électricité pour les véhicules si
vous voulez avoir une politique
ambitieuse de transport par véhicule
électrique il nous faudra plus
d'électricité trème observation nous
devons
privilégier les filières qui émettent le
moins de CO2 et de gaz à effet de serre
à cet égard puisque vous vous référez
sans le dire à l'Allemagne je me permets
de rappeler que l'électricité produite
en Allemagne produit six fois plus de
CO2 et de gaz à effet de serre qu'en
France l'Allemagne a fait le choix du
charbon c'était il y a encore quelques
années 30 % du charbon qui permettait de
produire l'électricité aujourd'hui on
est passé à 40 % et en plus il s'agit
d'un char charbon plutôt poussièreux
très poant qu le ligite le reste étant
conforté par notamment le recours au
gaz voilà pourquoi l'Allemagne produit
beaucoup de CO2 et de gaz à effet de
serre et le compte dans cette affaire
c'est que c'est pour beaucoup des tonnes
de charbon qui ont traversé l'Atlantique
vendu à bas prix par les États-Unis qui
dispose aujourd'hui d'autres ressources
que l'on appelle les gaz gaz de chist
et que finalement c'est cette
électricité qui nous est revendue que
dis revendue qui nous est offerte par
des prix négatifs par le jeu des
transferts d'un pays à
l'autre 4e observation nous devons avoir
un système qui soit
compétitif et qui nous permette de
disposer d'un avantage commercial et là
les chiffres que je me permets de citer
à nouveau puisque nous avons déjà eu un
débat avec votre prédécesseur madame
madame la ministre mais je vous les
recite les chiffres sont
accablants on veut dénoncer le
nucléaire les 58
réacteurs qui ont été construits en
France la 2e génération ont coûté 96
milliards d'euros valeur
2014 et ils produisent il faut le
rappeler l'essentiel de notre
électricité nous avons 128000
installé en France un peu plus de la
moitié viennent du nucléaire or le
nucléaire produit 65 % de notre
électricité en Allemagne l'Allemagne
certes a beaucoup investi dans l'éolien
dans le photovoltaïque citons les
chiffres l'éolien l'Allemagne a investi
40 milliards
d'euros que produisent ces 40 milliards
d'euros ils produisent 20 taw
par rapport à la France nous avons un
parc nucléaire qui produit 400
tawh sur une consommation globale qui
est à peu près de 460
entendez bien le chiffre 40 milliards
d'euros pour produire 20 TW mais le
photovoltaïque aura coûté 112 milliards
d'euros pour produire 12
terraw évidemment de ce fait nous avons
un vrai avantage compétitif
que je n'entends pas cont dilapide au
profit d'un certain nombre d'idées qui
sont plus proches des idéologies que des
programme de
gouvernement j'ajoute d'ailleurs une
chose nous avons aujourd'hui en France
une électricité qui est à peu près deux
fois moins chè qu'en Allemagne sauf que
sauf que madame la ministre je me
permets de vous faire une recommandation
toute particulière dans les discussions
que vous allez avoir au plan européen et
dans la rédaction du projet de loi sur
la transition énergétique l'Allemagne a
mis dans sa loi la possibilité pour les
électrointensifs les gros consommateurs
d'électricité de ne pas payer le
transport de l'électricité qui est une
part importante de la
facture le président de la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie qui
rencontré une commission de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a quelques semaines
annoncé plutôt une bonne nouvelle à
savoir que la creux avait mais pour
l'année 2014 décidé de diminuer de 50 %
le tarif du transport profit des gros
consommateurs mais il a souligné qu'il
ne pouvait pas aller au-delà sauf
support
législatif je vous encourage vivement
dans l'intérêt de notre pays à regarder
cette question la voie est ouverte la
solution est proposée qui vous permett
bien de donner aux entreprises
françaises qui consomment le plus
d'électricité un avantage comparable à
celui que les Allemands réussi à
accorder à leur propre patrimoine
industriel
5e
recommandation nous devons madame la
ministre capitaliser sur ce qui marche
bien en France et sur les ressources
éventuellement
disponibles j'ai entendais tout à
l'heure l'orateur du groupe écologiste
parler du tout nucléaire il n'a jamais
exist certes le nucléaire représente une
part importante
dans la production
d'électricité mais il n'a jamais été
voulu par aucun gouvernement qu'il soit
de droite ou de
gauche de produire toute l'électricité à
partir du nucléaire certes les Allemands
si vous prenez le même raisonnement mon
cher collègue ont fait le choix du tout
charbon tout charbon et énergie fossile
avec tous les inconvénients que j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure alors en France
nous avons un programme
nucléaire 58 réacteurs 2e génération 2e
génération nous avons une génération
numéro 3 avec le Pr de
Flamanville est-ce que pour autant il
faut que nous baissions les bras et que
nous renoncions à une filière qui a fait
ses preuves et qui emploie autant de
personnes et qui est une vraie référence
dans beaucoup de pays certes des pays
pour des raisons encore une fois plutôt
idéologiqu ont renoncé au nucléaire mais
il y en a d'autres qui au contraire se
prépare à accueillir des centrales
nucléaires est-ce que la France va se
retrouver au ban des accusés au point de
ne pas pouvoir défendre les atouts de
notre industrie au profit de ces pays
qui sont particulièrement
demandeurs évidemment se pose une
question l'avenir de
je passe au silence un des engagements
du Parti socialiste d'avant les
élections où il était question de
supprimer 24 réacteurs d'ici à 2025 je
pense que tout cela a été oublié je ne
peux que vous féliciter de l'avoir fait
néanmoins Fessenheim est devenu un
trophée brandi devant vos alliés peut-on
encore parler d'alliés vos
voisins proches que sont les écologistes
il faut fermer
fenhe votre prédécesseur avait été très
clair à cette
tribune la centrale de Fessenheim sera
fermée avant 2016 c'est dans 2
ans je me suis permis de lui dire mais
je me permettrai pas de le faire
vis-à-vis de vous parce que je suis
persuadé que vous avez une capacité à
faire beaucoup mieux que votre
prédécesseur autrement d'ailleurs vous
n'auriez pas été nommé à ce poste
là je ne suis pas sûr qu'il soit
possible de faire ferm fheim d'ici à 2
ans d'abord parce qu'il y a des
procédures qu'il faut respecter auprès
de l'Agence de sûreté
nucléaire et puis et
puis que va devenir l'Alsace
F apporte 85 %
d'électricité nécessaire en Alsace et je
ne parle pas des emplois ils sont plus
de 1000 sur le site et je ne parle pas
évidemment des emplois indirects
je me permets de dire ici à la tribune
je veux bien être trompé par les faits
je suis convaincu que vous n'y
arrivrierez pas et vous n'y arriverez
pas car ce serait une grave erreur on
entend parfois ça c'est un langage
militant c'est une vieille centrale il
n'y a pas de vieille centrale nucléaire
mes chers collègues en France toutes les
centrales sont
régulièrement modifié dans leur
structure pas de béton bien sûr
industriel et régulièrement mise aux
normes pour pouvoir répondre aux
nécessités de l'agence de de l'Autorité
de sûreté nucléaire la France peut se
vanter d'avoir une autorité qui est
incontestée c'est certainement celle qui
est la plus respectée dans le monde la
preuve en est c'est qu'au moment de
Fukushima c'est l'ASN de la France qui a
été en mesure de produire les meilleures
informations et les meilleurs
diagnostics sur l'accident qui s'était
produit
parlant des ressources éventuellement
disponibles je ne veux pas même si cela
sera court ne pas mettre dans mon propos
la question des gaz de
schye Madame la Ministre le Parlement a
voté et c'est la loi du 13 juillet 2011
une loi qui interdit qui interdit
l'exploitation des gaz de schiste par la
fracturation hydraulique mais cette loi
comporte des dispositions que le
gouvernement devrait respecter qui
consiste notamment à permettre à la
recherche de se poursuivre et à des
expérimentations d'être réalisé pour
vérifier d'ailleurs c'est un préalable
si nous avons effectivement de telles
ressources en hydrocarbures sous nos
pieds
autre observation et je me rapproche des
question purement européenne il faut
remettre au centre de la politique
européenne madame la
ministre une politique qui privilégie
comme
étant vraiment l'objectif essentiel la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre et de
CO2 de ce point de vue là il faut
constater que le marché du carbone est
devenu complètement
plat j'ai regardé les chiffres avant de
monter à la tribune en l'espace de 8 ans
de 2006 à 2014 le prix du carbone a été
divisé par 10 il était de 30 € en 2006
il est aujourd'hui de 3 € et je me
réfère pas à des périodes plus anciennes
où le prix du la tonne de carbone était
beaucoup plus
élevé autre recommandation
l'architecture du marché de
l'électricité en
Europe aujourd'hui on le voit bien et le
président de la creux l'a très
pertinemment souligné lors de son
audition devant une commission de
l'Assemblée
nationale l'Europe au niveau de la
commission mais les gouvernements sont
également responsables n'a pas cherché
la cohérence entre une politique climat
et une politique énergie
l'incoréence est telle que l'on voit
deux voies parallèles qui ont été suivis
par des équipes complètement différentes
certaines se sont préoccupées de fixer
des objectifs dans le domaine du climat
et d'autres se sont attachés à organiser
le marché de
l'électricité on peut on peut avancer
que les deux équipes ne se sont pas
vraiment parlé or aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin de mettre de la cohérence au
niveau européen nous avons besoin de
faire qu'il y ait une vraie force
européenne dans le domaine de l'énergie
alors cette force doit s'appuer
madame la ministre sur quelques idées
simples un il faut d'abord des filières
qui soient efficaces le rapport coût
efficacité déterminant et quand je dis
l'efficacité elle n'est pas
qu'économique elle est également
environnementale il faut faire en sorte
que nous apportions à nos concitoyens
une énergie la plus propre possible et
de ce point de vue là je le redis avec
beaucoup de fermeté la France n'a aucune
leçon voir au contraire elle pourrait si
on voulait l'entendre en donner et en
même temps le coup de façon à ce que
l'électricité soit accessible au plus
grand nombre et dans d'autres enceintes
je l'aurais fait je n'en ai pas le temps
la question de la précarité énergétique
est une question importante qu'il faut
traiter avec beaucoup
d'attention mais pour que l'Europe est
une véritable politique il faut d'abord
que les réseaux soient renforcés on
parle beaucoup de l'énergie d'origine
éolienne qui vient d'Allemagne est-ce
qu'on s'est attardé sur le sentiment des
populations traversées par ces réseaux
il y a des
Lander en Allemagne où on assiste à une
vraie montée en charge des personnes qui
ne supportent pas l'émergence de réseau
et de pyone au profit de région du sud
de l'Allemagne ou tout simplement de la
France la France achète aujourd'hui
des quantité importante d'électricité et
comme je le disais tout à l'heure elle
n'achète pas c'est un prix négatif on le
lui donne pour une raison simple madame
la min mais vous le savez c'est que
l'énergie produite par des éoliennes et
par des panneaux photovoltaïques doit
être évacué l'énergie électrique
produite doit être consommée doit être
évacuée et c'est la raison pour laquelle
et bien on préfère payer le consommateur
payer
l'électricité au profit du consommateur
français et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a ainsi de l'électricité
un prix négatif ne dites pas comme je
l'ai entendu pas ici mais dans d'autres
salle que simplement c'est grâce aux
énergies renouvelables qui seraient
tellement compétitive que finalement les
voisin en serait régalé non parce que
finalement cette électricité oblige
éteindre des centres de production pas
seulement en Allemagne vous le savez on
a fermé des centrales au gaz
particulièrement performante qui venaent
d'être construite mais c'est vrai
également pour la France où nous avons
monsieur le Président j'en ai quasiment
terminé où nous avons effectivement un
certain nombre de de problèmes à régler
alors je termine simplement madame la
ministre en disant si vous voulez avoir
une vraie politique européenne de
l'énergie il faut tout faire pour
soutenir la recherche et l'innovation
c'est dans ce domaine qui a le plus à
faire sur le choix des filières
technologiques les plus performantes et
les moins plantes et puis sur la
question du stockage de l'électricité
vous vous êtes exprimé la semaine
dernière sur ce sujet dans le cadre
d'une réunion que vous avez eu avec la
commission des affaires économiques il y
a des solutions je rappelle quand même
que grâce au nucléaire on alimente 6000
MW
de pompage de station de pompage qui
nous per permet de stocker la Nuit de
l'eau qui est ensuite utilisée dans la
journée ce sont madame la ministre
quelques observations que je voulais
faire qui je l'avais dit tout à l'heure
prenait la forme d'une recommandation
permettez que d'une façon très modeste
j'ai essayé simplement de contribuer à
l'édification d'une vraie politique
ambitieuse dans le domaine de
l'énergie merci mon cher collègue dans
la suite du débat la parole est à Madame
Chantal joanau pour 10 minutes ah
on voulait me renir à la
tribune madame la
ministre mes chers collègues d'abord je
veux vous remercier pour l'initiative de
ce débat à
quelques mois enfin un an et quelques
mois de la prochaine conférence sur le
climat en France et juste just te
rappeler qu'on parle là aujourd'hui de
la question du climat et de l'énergie en
Europe on n'est pas sur un débat sur la
question pure énergie notamment en en
France et peut-être utile en parlant du
climat de rappeler ce que nous dit la
science il y a pas de climatosceptique
ici mais ça peut être utile de rappeler
ce que dit la science elle nous dit
grosso modo qu'il faut pas dépasser
effectivement un réchauffement de
l'ordre de 2°grés celus par rapport à
l'air
pré-industrielle elle nous dit la
science et le derniers rapport du GC l'a
clairement confirmé que nous avons déjà
un acquis de
0,8°g celus et que nous sommes sur une
trajectoire de
4°g aujourd'hui elle nous rappelle juste
que l'air glaciire c'était en moyenne
moin 4,5° celus par rapport à la moyenne
des températures aujourd'hui donc en
d'autres termes nous sommes aujourd'hui
sur une trajectoire
dangereuse une trajectoire dangereuse
sur le plan économique
juste pour mémoire là aussi un
réchauffement de l'ordre d'un degr celus
dans une région correspond à une baisse
de la croissance de 1,3 points dans
cette région c'est pas une assemblée de
chevelu à sandalette qu'il a écrit c'est
la Banque mondiale dans son dernier
rapport qui s'appelle turnown The heit
elle nous rappelle aussi que cette
trajectoire est dangereuse en terme de
sécurité ça c'est dans le dernier
rapport du GC les questions de l'eau se
poseront en Afrique en Europe ce seront
des problèmes et d'inondation
et d'épidémie lié au changement
climatique ce sont des millions de
personnes qui vont être déplacées à
travers le monde pour lesqueles nous
n'avons pas encore réfléchi à un statut
de déplacés environnementaux ce sont le
problème des ressources aliotiques les
ressources aliotiques c'est grosso modo
12 % des personnes à travers le monde
qui vivent des ressources aliotiques
vous savez que le pH des océans n'a
jamais varié depuis 100 millions
d'années or avec le surplu des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre nous observons
depuis quelques années une variation
d'acidité des océans nous ne savons
absolument pas comment ce milieu va
pouvoir s'adapter à cette à cette
évolution donc on a un sujet fondamental
qui se pose en termes économique en
terme de sécurité donc un sujet régalien
en soi puisque finalement c'est un peu
le rôle des des états de traiter de ces
de ces questions et face à cela une
communauté internationale qui discours
une Europe qui vote qui vote qui
s'engage elle est plutôt l'Europe est
plutôt précurseur sur ces sujets mais
les résultats ne sont pas totalement là
certes on est plutôt bon mais on observe
que d'autres continents évoluent très
très vite et risque dans certains
domaines de nous donner des leçons assez
rapidement et je vous renvoie quand même
au rapport de la Cour des comptes sur la
mise en œuvre du paquet climat énergie
qui est un peu sceptique sur
l'efficacité des différents instruments
et je m'étonne que face à tout cela on
est pu voter au sein de l'Union
européenne un budget en baisse tout
particulièrement dans les domaines de
l'innovation
avec un budget consacré à
l'environnement et au changement
climatique dérisoire de l'ordre de 400
millions d'euros par an dérisoire alors
que nous devrions faire strictement
l'inverse strictement l'inverse on
devrait mettre le paquet sur
l'innovation on devrait mettre en commun
nos moyens de recherche notamment sur
les secteurs d'avenir ce sont les
énergies marines c'est le stockage de
l'énergie ça a été cité ça a été cité
tout à l'heure c'est la gestion de
l'énergie ce sont les ressources
stratégiques aussi qui seront
nécessaires demain et nous faisons
strictement l'inverse donc notre
première conviction nous l'avons porté
notamment au sein du programme pour les
européensnes notre première conviction
est que cette politique doit être la
nouvelle ambition de l'Europe comme on a
créé l'Europe autour de la SEA parce
qu'à l'époque on considérait que le
charbon et l'acier étaient des
ressources stratégiques pour le
développement des des pays aujourd'hui
on devrait constituer l'Europe autour
des énergies du futur mutuiser nos
moyens de recherche avoir des ressources
propres dans le budget européen qui
serait justement Ori orienté vers ces
secteurs nous plaidons pour n'imposer le
choix du nucléaire à personne parce que
cert le débat est pas écologique mais
que les pays fassent des arbitrages qui
soi différents on peut le respecter on
doit le respecter mais que par contre
l'Europe soit véritablement un centre un
centre pour développer toutes ces
énergies du futur moi tout ce que je
vois aujourd'hui c'est la Chine la Chine
investit massivement dans ces secteurs
parce qu'elle est tout à fait conscience
que celui qui maîtrisera et le solaire
et le stockage de l'énergie le solaire
est une énergie formidable c'est la
dernière qu'on est en fait découverte
bah il sera le roi du pétrole demain
sans jeu de mot bien évidemment
et sur ce débat vraiment il faut arrêter
de dire c'est le nucléaire versus les
énergies renouvelables et les énergies
du futur faut arrêter ce débat parce
qu'on regarde pas vers l'avenir on
regarde pas vers le développement de nos
pays notre deuxième conviction c'est que
on peut relever on doit relever ce défi
avec l'Afrique on est les seuls
finalement en Europe à ne pas voir qu'à
côté de chez nous un continent est en
train d'exploser et sur le plan
démographique et sur le plan de sa
croissance et que si nous n'arrivons pas
avant cette conférence à Paris à avoir
un projet de développement Europe
Afrique nous aurons du mal à amener avec
nous les autres pays notre troisème
conviction c'est que l'Europe doit
profondément réformer son système
économique et fiscal il y aura pas
d'innovation écologique si on ne bascule
pas la fiscalité qui pèse sur le travail
vers une fiscalité qui pèse sur la
pollution et c'est green washing
d'affirmer que la modernisation
écologique est possible sans une
fiscalité écologique donc nous plaidons
pour que l'Europe se dote d'un prix du
carbone notre 4ème conviction est que
l'Europe doit doublement réviser ses
objectifs il faut réviser son objectif
en terme de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre 2030 une ambition
de 50 % est atteignable c'était plus
difficile à court terme mais à 2030
c'est atteignable et je ne suis pas
totalement en phase avec ronand dantech
il y avait d'autres points que je
partager mais je ne suis pas totalement
en phase même pas du tout d'ailleurs
pour dire que l'objectif de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
doit être un trè objectif et pas un
premier objectif ça doit rester le
premier le premier objectif deuxième
objectif nous devons prendre en compte
non pas la réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre mais l'empreunte
carbone parce que certes on dit oh la
France c'est formidable depuis 1990 nous
avons réduit nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre plus que le protocole de
Kyoto nous l'imposit sauf que ce qu'on
oublie de dire c'est que c'est en partie
en grande partie liée à la
désindustrialisation et que quand on
prend en compte l'empreinte carbone
celle-ci elle ne cesse de croître donc
c'est un débat un petit peu hypocrite
que de ne pas vouloir poser sur la table
cette question de l'empreunte carbone
puisque finalement la planète ne gagne
absolument rien à cette
désindustrialisation de de la France
donc nous plaidons pour que ces
objectifs soient bien en terme
d'empreinte carbone avec un corollaire
qui est la mise en place d'une
contribution carbone aux frontières de
l'Europe sur les produits importés enfin
not notre 5ème conviction c'est que
entre l'Europe qui est vraiment
l'échelle pertinente
ensuite c'est pas l'état ce sont les
territoires ce sont les régions qui sont
les plus pertinents pour conduire ces
politiques donc on est favorable à ce
que la politique de l'énergie soit
transférée au niveau des régions
qu'elles ai une véritable compétenence
d'expérimentation elles sont les mieux
placéses pour résoudre ce problème de la
précarité énergétique et qu'elles
puissent expérimenter de nouveaux
modèles que ce soit des modèles
coopératifs ou collaboratifs je suis
assez convaincu par le système des
coopératives énergétiques dans C
dans certains secteurs voilà rapidement
j'ai pas tenu tout mon temps mais c'est
pas grave voilà rapidement cinq
convictions ça a une proposition et
vraiment une certitude c'est que quand
on parle quand on a ce débat important
c'est un beau débat quand même de de
parler de la question du climat en
Europe une vraie certitude c'est que le
prochain projet européen après avoir été
la SEA après avoir été l'agriculture
après avoir été le marché commun devrait
être justement ce secteur des énergies
du futur et de l'innovation
merci ch
cèg dans la suite du débat la parole est
à Madame Eveline Didier pour 9
minutes merci
Monsieur monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers
collègues nous mes chers
collègues d'avoir initié ce débat
relatif au climat et à l'énergie en
Europe nous avons eu des déjà des
intervention de qualité et on voit bien
que ce n'est pas ce débat là qui va
résoudre la question mais nous avons en
tout cas vu un certain nombre de points
de vue qui sont intéressants et qui
méritent d'être exprimés le sujet est
large et ce d'autant plus qu'il
nécessite une mise en perspective
internationale en effet la question du
climat ne connait pas de
frontières les conséquences dramatiques
du réchauffement climatique appellent
une réponse globale solidaire et
concertée des États du monde entier quel
chantier c'est pourquoi les engagements
qui seront pris dans le cadre du Sommet
de Banky Moon à l'automne prochain
pèseront lourd nous le savons en
particulier au regard des positions
prises par des pays jusqu'ici très
sceptiques très en retrait et dans la
perspective de notre de 2015 à Paris
le 13 avril le nouveau rapport du GC
destiné à promouvoir auprès des états
des pistes pour notamment décarboner
leur économie a rappelé encore une fois
l'urgence à agir la croissance des
émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre n'a jamais été aussi rapide les
experts du GC préconise de réduire ses
émissions de 40 % à 70 % d'ici à 2050 et
de les ramener à un niveau proche de 0
d'ici la fin du siècle autrement dit
c'est lourd tous les secteurs de
l'économie sont concernés l'énergie mais
aussi l'agriculture le bâtiment les
transports j'en oublie sans doute ainsi
les transports par la route ou les air
qui se sont intensifiés en raison de la
multiplication des échanges commerciaux
sont de forts émetteurs de gaz à effet
de serre c'est pourquoi lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique nécessite
également de reconnaître les coûts
écologiques et sociaux de l'économie
mondialisée et d'adopter une méthode
normative mais sans doute aussi un
travail au niveau local beaucoup
beaucoup plus important aujourd'hui
enfin la nécessité d'agir et de diminuer
l'utilisation des énergies fossiles de
réduire les gaz à effet de sererme ne
fait plus
débat nul n'ignore aujourd'ui les effets
du changement climatique notamment sur
les populations les plus vulnérables ni
les conséquences à venir je n'y
reviendrai pas ça a été très bien
détaillé dans son excellent avis sur
l'adaptation au changement climatique la
section environnement du Conseil
économique et social et environnemental
partage le bilan établi par de nombreux
acteurs institutionnels ou de la société
civile il note ainsi que je cite le
réchauffement pourrait suivant
l'importance des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre atteindre dans notre pays
environ 1,5°gr en 2050 et entre 2,5 et
3,5 en 2100 mais à condition vraiment de
de déjà 6 m donc mais en tout cas c'est
un scénario qui est tout à fait probable
alors rappelons les régions montagneuses
seront touché par une diminution de
l'enngement une quasi disparition des
glaciers c'est demain tandis que l' du
niveau de la mer aura des conséquences
importantes dans certaines régions
côtières particulièrement sensibles à la
montée des EAU on sait déjà on a les
cartes de là où les côtes vont être
reniées bien les régions ultramarines
auront également à faire face à ce
réchauffement avec des conséquences
spécifiques risque d'intensification des
cyclones tropicaux les plus violents
acidification de l'océan ça a été dit
qui rendra encore plus fragile la survie
d'écosystème lié à certains récipes
coraliens et c'est important sans parler
de toutes les conséquences social que
qui ont été aussi évoqué que je ne peux
décliner ici et je voudrais faire une
parenthèse pour rappeler l'initiative de
notre collègue Paul vergess qui a attiré
l'attention il nous l'a dit ce matin du
président de la commission du
développement durable et et qui va
prochainement nous solliciter les uns et
les autres dans tous les groupes pour
lancer une nous proposer une démarche
qui vise à faire prendre conscience de
l'importance de nos secteurs ultra
et notamment de la spécificité des îles
et de la problématique des îles qui est
particulière mais je pense que ça vous
intéressera tous et j'espère qu'en tout
cas tous les bancs soutiendront cette
initiative après l'échec de nombreux
sommets consacrés à la question parfois
en raison du faible champ d'application
de l'effet contraignant des objectifs
Kyoto ça concerernit à peu près 15 % des
émissions mondiales la conférence de
Paris en 2015 ne pas ne doit pas être ne
peut pas être un rendez-vous manqué
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre ce débat
sur le climat et l'énergie en Europe
tout de suite la suite de nos programmes
sur public
sénna